hurricane Ian is bearing down on the
State of Florida after ravaging Cuba
we've talked about it to some degree as
of this moment two and a half million
Floridians are without power and we are
told that fatalities are in the hundreds
the federal government should do what it
can to help Florida that is my position
it has been the case with hurricanes in
other states and tornadoes and whatever
else I am consistent on that issue but
many Republicans are not we've seen so
many Republicans vote against Federal
funding for disasters in other states
but then go and beg the federal
government for help when the disaster is
in their state that gets us to Florida
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis Ron
DeSantis who has been one of the wildest
critics of President Joe Biden is now
all of a sudden being very nice because
he needs Joe Biden's help he needs the
federal government's help what happened
to Florida being a big boy patriotic
self-sufficient State who doesn't need
anybody's help and they have all the
freedom in the world well all of a
sudden they're issuing mandatory
evacuation orders which I agree with but
they're not exactly the freedom that Ron
DeSantis has touted all of a sudden
DeSantis wants Federal cash for disaster
relief even though DeSantis in 2013
voted no for superstorm Sandy Relief
funding for New York and New Jersey is
he a hypocrite of course he is but it's
been really funny watching him try to
equip equivocate when being interviewed
by Sean Hannity on Fox News which we're
going to get to in a moment Newsweek
article DeSantis Praises Biden as
Florida Governor changes tone before
hurricane Ian what a surprise what a
surprise Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
has expressed gratitude towards
President Joe Biden for his cooperation
as hurricane Ian is due to hit the state
let's take a look at the video clip
which you will find uh is the Santa
singing a very different tone about Joe
Biden let's talk about you had a
conversation with the president today
earlier in the day there had been talk
that the president spoke with Mayors but
not you uh but apparently the president
reached out to you tonight can you tell
us about that conversation and in the
aftermath of the storm what what support
Floridians can expect from the federal
government
well Sean you know what I said today is
uh you know my phone lines open When
people's lives and their property are at
risk like this you know we all need to
work together right when people's lives
are at risk we need to work together
otherwise I'm going to tell horrible
corrosive lies regardless of party lines
uh the bind Administration has approved
our request for a pre-landfall
declaration and did that very quickly so
so we're thankful for that you know
obviously as this the impacts are known
uh you know there's going to be more
requests particularly for individual
assistance for Floridians that may have
been displaced you know and it's my
sense that the administration you know
wants to help I think they realize that
this is a really significant storm and
there's a lot of people that you know
we're working with the locals we work
very well with them of course at the
state level but we really need everyone
working together to make sure people
have their needs tended to this is about
a bunch of different things so let's see
if we can go through it first of all is
DeSantis a hypocrite on this issue of
federal funding of course he is and so
many Republicans are you had
um members elected officials from the
Midwest who were begging for money for
tornado uh uh recovery who had voted
against money for New York and New
Jersey for superstorm Sandy recovery
back in 2013 and I could go on the list
is so long and the earthquakes the Rand
Paul Kentucky all these different
they're they're all Hypocrites okay so
that's one layer and DeSantis is of
course a hypocrite second thing
when DeSantis talks about this is not
the time for pettiness this is not the
time for political division Etc he's
agreeing that much of what he does is
simply Petty
and when it's inconvenient or whether he
believes that people's lives are
actually on the line he didn't seem to
believe it with covet but now with the
hurricane he seems to all of a sudden he
goes no this isn't the time for any of
that now we're just going to behave like
normal people and we're actually going
to work together because we actually
need need something here so that's the
second thing is he's essentially
admitting a lot of his uh his nonsense
is completely Petty and merely political
but then there's a third aspect which is
that Rhonda santis is on the
gubernatorial ballot in what is it five
weeks five and a half weeks or something
like that he will either be re-elected
the governor of Florida potentially
booing him into running for president in
2024 or he will lose to Charlie Chris
now the polling looks fine for DeSantis
right now for the most part save one
recent poll but DeSantis is also acting
this way out of self-preservation
because he realizes much like Trump's
covid response destroyed Trump's
re-election and much like bad disaster
responses in other states have
dramatically impacted the approval
ratings of those leaders think Greg
Abbott in Texas although Abbott has now
recovered it's been long enough he'll
probably still win re-election to
Governor against Beto in Texas DeSantis
realizes that the timing of this
hurricane if there were to be a bad
response would be really bad for his
re-election so that's what's happening
oh and then there's a fourth aspect to
this as well
the Trump narcissistic Style
is extraordinarily transactional and so
to some degree this is also DeSantis
thinking to himself
if I'm nicer to Biden on TV the federal
government might give us more money and
of course Biden knows that this is what
DeSantis is doing but to praise Biden
quite frankly Biden doesn't care Biden
realizes that it's his job to say yes
when Americans need something Americans
in Florida need something right now so
Biden's going to get them the money
Biden's not perfect there's no doubt
about it but on this there is a really
sharp contrast between Biden and Trump
trump even in situations of disaster
relief is extraordinarily Petty and
narcissistic and political Biden's just
going to send the money Biden doesn't
really care whether Ron DeSantis is
being nice to him on TV or not so
there's the santis all of a sudden
saying no I mean things are going fine
with Biden and we know all the reasons
why four different layers as to why this
is what's going on
one of our sponsors today is BusyBox
child I know that there are many parents
in our audience this is for you BusyBox
child offers really great subscription
boxes for kids filled with sensory toys
that will help your toddler to
Elementary age child stay off screens
and do some really interesting stuff
technology used by kids is at an
all-time high especially after the
pandemic playing off of screens is
really critical for development for
cognitive development social emotional
well-being for kids it's an ideal
opportunity for parents to engage with
kids as well Carolyn is the founder of
busy box child she's a mom and a child
clinical psychologist who designs all
the boxes that you receive busy box
child offers monthly sensory kits with
different themes for each season or you
can get a monthly sand bin subscription
for hours and hours of fun check out
their mini jars and mini kits for
playtime on the go BusyBox child is a
small business that supports the David
Pacman show support them go to
busyboxchild.com and use the code Pacman
for 10 off the link is down below